he has his many touchdown passes as
Johnny Manziel in the NFL he's LaDainian
Tomlinson Hall of Fame running back on
loan from the NFL Network
good morning LaDainian good morning Dan
and that was a terrific introduction
thank you
seven career touchdown passes did you
know that you had as many touchdown
passes as Johnny Manziel I did not know
Walter Payton had eight maybe yes sir
yeah I tried to catch him but I missed
Antonio Gates wide open one game and I
kind of blew it for me
let it go all right it's okay you did
okay in your career
all right assess the Rams Jaguars trade
I know we like to say who won in loss we
don't know what these graphics are going
to turn into but what do you make of
what the rams are trying to do well any
time you you know can get a top corner d
top corner on the market and the guy
that's going to you know obviously
totally change your defense when you
already have the best defender in
football and Aaron Donald I mean you
have to say right away that the Rams you
know won this trade because I'm not you
know Dan I'm just not you know believer
in saying oh you get to first-round
picks and you know that that's the value
of the Jalen Ramsey well as you just
mentioned we do not know what those
first-round picks are going to be like
they can be bust you know for all we
know and so at this point I'm saying the
Rams have made it clear that they're
going forward they're going to be you
know proactive and try to take advantage
of the market when they can and getting
a guy like Jalen Ramsay but I look at
that offensive line and I look at you
know Todd Gurley and his availability
they still didn't address the bigger
problem with me and that is that
offensive line and if you're not buying
on me biting on play-action with Todd
Gurley not being in there I I still
think you still have a big problem here
if you're going to try to compete in
that division with the Niners and
Seahawks well you bring up a good point
but here but here's the thing I think we
have to keep in mind
offensive line is hard to improve
offensive line during the season you
know you look at Trevor Williams is out
there he hasn't come in yet but there
are a lot of teams that won't train
Williams but the Redskins won't come off
of them so how do you improve a line
during the season it's hard yeah you
know the other thing is I'm not as
concerned with their running game as a
lot of people might think without our
Gurley I think both of those guys you
know brown and and the young kid
Henderson maybe they can suffice you
know what Todd Gurley has been given
them Todd is a special individual I will
say that but right now he's not because
he's hurt I like Henderson I just don't
know if they trust him yet but I I was
wondering do you think two first-round
draft picks for the Rams to Washington
would have gotten you Trent Williams oh
you would think so but would you rather
have him or would you rather have Jalen
Ramsey you got address boat I mean why
not the you know they they have already
made the statement that they're going
all in so why not why not go try to get
both of those guys how would you
characterize the state of officiating so
far I feel like you know our officials
are you know like they're scared to make
a mistake out there and so they're
trying to make the right call on it all
the time instead of saying you know what
just just let these guys play in the
obvious cause that's the dusted thing if
it's obvious then make the call but if
it has no bearing on the place backside
you call it a holding and on the run
play this front side this guy gets out
for 40 yards like I you know that's
that's just a bad call to me and so I
feel like dan that they're just trying
to be too perfect yeah I did I don't
know if you get the same feeling but
whenever I see a long run or long pass I
just assume there's gonna be a flag I
like there there's no rhythm to the game
it's just a viewer I don't know how it
be trying to play the game but it just
feels like there's a flag you know the
Jets and the Cowboys I think there were
six or seven
- plays late in the game when there's a
flag on every plane yeah and you know
what then I feel like because of that I
think it's you know the media attention
that now these reps you know have you
know what we're looking at them now you
know we're revealing all these plays on
on that different network sports
networks calling out the officials and
now there is replay and this summer at
my Country Club here in Texas
some of the referees were here to play
golf they were having their conference
over in Frisco right and so I got to
talking to him about this just replay
stuff and they said Lt you know the NFL
has opened up a can of worms they have
no idea what they've just done and you
know I thought about that and it's
because whenever you put that type of
pressure on these these guys who are not
supposed to be a parent in the game
right we're not supposed to know they're
there it's all about the game well now
you have brought them into the game so I
mean I agree with those guys it's tough
to be a referee right now he's LaDainian
Tomlinson on loan from the NFL Network
and of course Thursday Night Football
continues this week Chiefs Broncos on
Fox NFL Network and Amazon Prime video
I've been stumping a few analysts who've
appeared on the program I've asked the
following question who is the best
second best team in the AFC I think it's
the Houston Texans okay
I think it's a Houston Texans right now
but that might change after one or two
weeks well it will jus will change as
Kansas City gets healthier and you know
they're they're going to have to do
something to fix those that that problem
with the defense I think a lot of it
Chris Jones has to play better yeah you
know he's a man in the middle of that
defense and he simply has to be better
if he wants to be considered you know
one of the best defensive tackles in
football and be paid like one then he
has to perform like one and so if he
gets it going I think it makes that
defense a lot better but the office once
Patrick is healthy on that ankle and is
he comes back and and Tyriq gifts in the
floor of this this all fence I think you
know they're going to be there man
they're just too tough time to panic if
you're the Cleveland Browns yes yes it
is you know my my question warrants
going into the season for the Cleveland
Browns really wasn't about the talent
honestly because you can accumulate
talent as we deal with the Jets you know
my first year we had all that talent and
we went to the AFC Championship game so
you can accumulate accumulate great
talent but it's all about who's coaching
them and to me you know Freddie Freddie
is just a little bit you know he's too
inexperienced right now to lead that
group to me you know he's making certain
decisions that to me are just not you
know it's not best for the team like for
example I think you know they need to
lead with nature like he needs to be a
focus of office everything has to come
around come off of nature but they're
trying to throw the ball around these
people on that offense you know but you
know what I don't like that and
experienced coaches do and I keep saying
they need to simplify things on offense
you've got a pretty good defense there
simplify and don't make these mistakes
by trying to be this explosive Kansas
City style offense play complimentary
football because that's your person now
that's who you have as you mentioned a
great a really good defense you know but
you got to help those guys out keep them
off the field keep them fresh and you do
that I started with Nick Chubb and I you
know
look you just said it I think they're
just trying to be someone that they're
not and frating you know because of the
relationship he has built with Baker and
that that truly got him the job their
relationship with Baker we know that so
he wants to appease you know Baker and
these Y receivers and make him look good
and all that stuff I get it but that's
what inexperienced coaches do if the
Browns don't make the playoffs finish
that sentence well I just think I think
you look at real hearted and in it you
know John Dorsey is a great football
mind so I believe John Dorsey looks at
this
team and says listen I need to maybe I
need to change it up maybe I do need to
bring in a experienced hair coach but I
have the feeling that they would at
least give Freddie another opportunity
next year I don't think he'll be one and
done are you nervous about the Cowboys
if you're a Cowboy fan no I'm not I mean
we talk about injuries all the time look
at what they're dealing with you know
the best left tackle in football Tyra
Smith has been out and I don't care what
anybody says that has hurt their
offensive line and hurt their office
because when you think they can't do
either one they can't run the football
on throw it you know every time dad
drops back he's getting hit pressure
Ezekiel is getting hit in the backfield
so that's offensive line play you know
once they get that solidified when he
comes back Amari Cooper is gonna be fine
you know III think the Cowboys would be
I think they're the best team in an FCS
I think they're better than the Eagles I
do did you grow up wanting to be a
cowboy I did I did yeah I grew up
wanting to be a cowboy and you know
obviously being from Texas and and and
you know those that mid-nineties team
you know when they obviously want three
straight Super Bowls man I was a you
know I was a junior high kid so imagine
that I had to start the Cowboys started
jacket you you thought you were a big
deal wearing that starter jacket right a
half-a-dozen McCaffrey I have a
legitimate chance to win the MVP I think
he I think he does have a legitimate
chance but you know like I know as a
runner you have to have a
record-breaking year to win MVP like you
have to do something truly special there
hasn't been done in a long time and you
know this discriminant seemed I think
he's on pace he has an opportunity to
break the scrimmage yards record but at
the same time I don't know that's enough
I don't think or not you're right it's
not enough because things that
Patrick my home is going to do and now
you talk about the show Watson entering
the conversation Russell Wilson
Russell Wilson absolutely and so those
guys will be there but but I'll tell you
here's the thing though they're
Christian McCaffrey
he plays over 95% of the plays so he's
going to get plenty of opportunities so
what if you know after the midway season
he just goes on the tear where he's just
you know scoring three touchdowns a game
he's putting up almost 200 yards again
and now you have to consider man this
guy could be the MVP so I don't want to
say he's totally out of it cuz I think
as much as he plays he's gonna have a
chance to win it
yeah but you had I think 1,600 yards in
100 catches one year you'd that one that
wasn't to win the NBA well and we were
we were falling 12 and I didn't even
make the Pro Bowl that you know I made
all protein but I didn't make the
process 1,600 yards in a hundred catches
yeah I think I was second in the league
in rushing hundred catches and they
didn't vote me to the Pro Bowl so I
still feel some type of way about that
you don't have Pro Bowls on my resume
you had over twenty three hundred yards
from scrimmage that season yeah didn't
make the Pro Bowl dang yeah hey it's
great to talk to you as always and
thanks for joining us sure Dan always a
pleasure man love coming on with you
mats LaDainian Tomlinson for more Dan
Patrick show tune in to audience Channel
239 on DirecTV stream for free on BR
live or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]